Speaker 1: Carrie Lake is now starting to
do Trump's dirty work. She is pounding Ron
DeSantis. We know Carrie Lake is desperate to be
Donald Trump's vice president. We know that Carrie
Lake is someone who is willing to do the dirty
work. And she's so desperate to be Trump's VP,
she can just taste it. She is now trying out
by going on TV and attacking Ron DeSantis here,
saying, why would Ron DeSantis even consider
running for president? He just was reelected.
He should really be staying in Florida.
Speaker 4: And the people of Florida just
reelected him. I'm assuming
when they reelected him,
they were hoping he'd stay around for a while.
So, I mean, he's I guess he's in his forties,
is about ten years younger than me. He's got a
long political future ahead of him. And I think
he should respect that. The people just voted him
in as governor and serve out that term for the
people of Florida, and then he could obviously run
for president. But this is President Trump's turn.
Speaker 1: And so. Oh, and there's one more clip.
Speaker 4: We haven't seen Ron DeSantis on the
world stage yet. And, you know, some of the
people that are surrounding him are kind
of the type of people that were pushing for
war, that were pushing for the endless war.
Speaker 1: And yeah, so a couple
of different things. First of all,
I had to look that up. Ron DeSantis is 44 years
old. When I look at the Santos, I don't see a guy
who's five years older than me. I see a guy who
looks 15 years older than me. He's genuinely 44
years old. That's stunning stuff. I mean, that's
an incredible, incredible thing to realize. And
I'm going to have to process that probably a
little bit later because it's bonkers. But the
most important thing to understand is that the
polling data supports the strategy of encourage
everybody but Ron DeSantis to run against Trump,
but try to keep Ron DeSantis out of the race. Why?
When you look at Republican polling, DeSantis is
the only person who polls well in a head to head
matchup against Donald Trump, Trump crushes Nikki
Haley in a head to head match up. Trump really
crushes everybody else, even people thinking
of running who have not yet announced. But
the more people you include in the polls, if you
say, who would you support if it was Trump versus
Nikki Haley versus Mike Pompeo versus Mike Pence
versus Tim Scott? The more people you include the.
Trump does because all those other people divide
up support except to Santos. Trump genuinely would
benefit from DeSantis not running. And so here
is Carrie Lake trying out for Trump's VP and
certainly willing to do the dirty work. Will it
work to get her that VP slot back? Axios report
we talked about yesterday says that indeed,
Trump is considering her for his running mate.